president joe biden visited the scene of
the latest school shooting adding
flowers to the growing memorial at rob
elementary school
the bidens viewed 21 portraits of grief
pausing it each to pay their respects
the first couple attended mass at sacred
heart catholic church before speaking
privately to the families who lost 19
children and two teachers
many welcomed the high-profile visitor
it shows that the nation
supports the families
and grieves with the families
but this isn't biden country this
community voted for donald trump by a
margin of 15 percent
personally as
someone that lives here
and feeling the grief
i don't think it's necessary
at any time much of this town of 16 000
can be found here in the center of town
[Applause]
for a song the comfort of company in
shared grief
[Music]
[Applause]
the uvalde town square features 21 white
crosses one for each of the victims of
tuesday's massacres and now they're
almost entirely obscured by the
thousands of flowers that people bring
by it wasn't on president biden's agenda
today
but it serves as a spot for people to
come and pay their respects
among those who came are local residents
veronica mendes and maria gear elsewhere
in the world
you don't
any civilian has no access
to this type of weapons some proponents
of
guns you would say
mention that
you know the solution is arming teachers
your teachers you say do you want to
carry a gun
no six-year-old kids in there they don't
know how to defend themselves from a
shooter
after video surfaced of parents urging
police to go inside officers
acknowledged it was a mistake to wait 78
minutes to enter the classroom and stop
the gunman
on sunday the department of justice
announced it would investigate why they
took so long
it was not the first mass shooting scene
biden has visited and it's unlikely to
be the last town in his tenure left to
grapple with grief john hendren al
jazeera uvalde texas